some of the most memorable moments in
csgo history have been pistol plays from
aces to clutches and many more here's
our list of the top 10 pro pistol plays
of all time stealing the 10th spot is
snacks is insane
for second pistol ace the most with
spontaneous next up car buff self our
9th spot goes to Dupree for his
disgusting equal round 8 against faze
clan at IEM katowice 2017 works though
this tournament and now we're getting
called
coming in eighth is nico wiping out
tighten with the deagle at ESL esea pro
league season 2 is gonna happen to
Dennis as well mouses buy is gonna be
torn away from them very very quickly by
sight oh my god shocks then has justify
one more the money isn't gonna touch him
and what on earth has just happened as
deagle is on fire shock just gonna walk
into as well nico is on fire coming in
7th is fanatics Dennis who proved
himself to be quite the Menace at the
semi-finals of ESL pro league season 3
smoking all five members of g2 esports
mere seconds after Saito kiss warned of
his pistol prowess you've said it enough
times and we've definitely seen it prove
that Dennis is extremely good on these
pistols to start that momentum on past
play q on point all three kills again
I'm done don't even buy guns just this
guy could use the u.s. beam for the
entire game and I would be convinced
because g2 is certainly has to be
convinced in my me
[Applause]
perfect what even say about how I'm not
that's this disgusting grabbing the
sixth spot is automatic who proved to be
a pistol God at ESL one cologne 2017
when he scored an insane 3k against the
reigning champs sk-gaming
with just four health on an eco round
during the grand final still have my
vision to win the exchange and the round
I would say is going to follow in
similar fashion as SK have full control
or do they all my goodness automatic for
HP plays two kills it's all for naught
perhaps or is it because schedule is
actually going on undetected they put so
much oh my god automatic another you
have to be kidding me that is the most
insane round a deagle has had yet in
this tournament poor HP and three kills
our fifth spot goes to shocks for making
selfish gaming a victim of a pretty
brutal pistol ace but hey if you're
going to get styled on it might as well
be at the hands of a Frenchman with
elegantly crossed hair coming out of the
doorway it's gonna be stream going down
shot oh sure I can't believe it he's
looking for the ACE here all on his own
Connor on the other side nice shot see
if are you kidding me that's gonna be
the ace in low round on real play coming
in fourth is FNX
and his East clutch at the IEM katowice
a 2016 grand final
while fnatic won the match three Oh
luminosity had moments of brilliance
including FNX is amazing pistol ace that
saw him clutch a 1v2 with the sliver of
health as he took down olofmeister and
Crim's I'll make it down the stairwell
and he's alone in his 1 on 2 he's
finally got the bomb he's got 25 seconds
that's not a lot of time if he runs
under here
how is he gonna get out from behind the
bomb box here
this to truancy can get the kill to step
on the bomb this is such a big risk
right now if an antique they're just not
buying it now they must have heard him
and they're gonna make the rotation but
the problem is now when he plants he
can't make it out and he's stuck in here
just getting the bomb down he's gonna
have to take the fight there after one
shot everything
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
coming in third is hiko although he has
a long list of epic clutches to his name
his greatest might be his ace against
sponsor list in civil season 8 2015
where he clutched a 1v5 on cash with a
tec-9 leading them on a chase around
quad we are very low displayed none of
these tears being seen where are the
knaves at there aren't any response
elicited have enough money or they've
already used them there's one Molotov
going in now the kills start to trickle
in forest fossils on the teeth inside it
well once again just be eco is about to
blow he's got three from behind quad can
he find a fourth he gets the fourth he's
odd for our second spot goes to Happy's
in st. Eagle A's team Envy enter
Dreamhack open London 2015 with the
simple strategy for spy and win eco
rounds it was a tactic that carried them
all the way to the grand final against
TSM thanks in no small part to Happy's
pistol proficiency you catch somebody
peak on envious side and well that's
what happens when you go around the
corner happy with wanting
[Applause]
Dupre is like sweating bullets our
number one spot goes to snacks is
legendary play during the grand final of
ESL one New York 2016 he manages the
score of one before clutch with the bomb
counting down to boot though not an ace
this USB clutch has all the elements of
the kind of legendary play that makes
you scream what in God's name is that
from snacks alley down in the end to
just snacks does find one on let's not
leave him out of this the Big Apple and
snacks is hungry he's got one kill
already on the USP low HP as well on
Guardian and flame he's trying to fake
them out trying to get them in the Buy
[Applause]
I've never seen anything like it what
the hell was that
and there you have it that was our list
for the top 10 best pistol plays of all
time which one do you think was the most
hype let us know in the comments section
below thanks for watching if you want
more great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
you